foreign
speaking of Education John BuzzFeed is
where I get all of my information
and this article came across the old
desk here and I thought you would like
it as I know you you don't look at a lot
of buzzfeeding the huge buds BuzzFeed
fan well here's the headline
um with what money Millennials and gen Z
are sharing the money tips they think
are super outdated considering the fact
we're all super broke very relatable
very empathetic on buzzfeed's part I I
see why this is so popular so I want to
read a few and get your your commentary
if you will here's one
someone said anytime someone tells me to
save money I automatically roll my eyes
I would love to be able to have a
savings of some kind but with inflation
twerking all over the place it's
impossible especially when my son keeps
growing out of his clothes every other
month even thrift store prices are
getting ridiculous
what do you think John
um
I think this is a case of
the great brene Brown says whatever you
go looking for in the world you're sure
to find
and so sometimes instead of staring at
the reality the totality of our reality
and that I realize that rhymes and I
should probably be an artist a poet
um if you got to look at all of your
reality including where you live what
you're doing for a living
what is reality for you right now I wish
I had all this extra time with my kids
but right now we're broke and we I I
can't afford that time right now because
I gotta go to another job like in this
hard heartbreaking conversations people
have in half
then somebody says hey you need to pay
your bills you need to work to save some
money
it's easy to laser in on that one little
word save and blow up all of the truth
and wisdom and that sentiment because
that particular thing doesn't apply to
you in this particular hard season that
you're in
um it's it's an easy way to avoid
reality and so
um
everyone should be saving money and not
everybody can right now both of those
things are true and so if that's not you
right now don't roll your eyes
exhale and say I'm gonna work really
hard and get there right that's good and
that's why our baby steps are one at a
time focused intensity yeah so we only
want you to save a thousand dollars when
you get started no more because it is
overwhelming and you have to sell some
stuff it's gonna be super uncomfortable
not fun anybody who goes into this thing
that's going to be a blast is Miss the
point completely it's not going to be
all right here's another one
someone said sell your car and get a
cheaper older one this is terrible
advice repairs and unreliable
Transportation or a financial Nightmare
and again that somebody saw the word
cheaper older the words cheaper older
one and they immediately went to it
falls apart and you can't have a cheaper
not in their mind they're picturing like
a 1970s Oldsmobile right or they're
picturing a a something that's not even
real they're not picturing anything
they're just trying to pull apart an
argument right what this is saying is uh
let me see this in a different way you
don't deserve
there's no Cosmic right to a new car
there's no Cosmic right to the car of
your dreams
that's why they call it of your dreams
because it's not real it's not a real
thing
um
when new cars are an all-time high and
so what they're saying is hey instead of
driving something older that's going to
catch on fire on the interstate because
someone drove it before me I'm gonna
drive a brand new 45
000 car under the guise of safety and
reliability right instead of I want it
because it makes me feel good and I want
to look good that's right and this
argument is particularly challenging
when someone brings it to you or me
because both of us are not car people
we've always driven used cars we always
drive old used cars I bought my first
new car I think ever the other day wow
at what age at 45 and so there we go I
made it right and so all I have to say
is like man you can have a great
wonderful wonderful great life with a
old cheaper used car absolutely and uh
there's no such thing as well it's gonna
have way more repairs and it's
unreliable do an inspection get a Honda
or your favorite the Toyotas and what
did you used to call them Toyota I do it
like Yoda from Star Wars and James gets
mad at me well so sorry it's my Arabic
accent coming out James sorry all right
here's one for you John
um I'm so sick of hearing that I should
buy a house right now just to have one
maybe that was a great idea a few years
ago but houses in my area are currently
selling for at least double maybe even
triple what they were three years ago
also along with home ownership comes a
regular and irregular costs that can
range from basic utilities to needing a
whole new roof it's just not realistic
or even logical this one I actually
agree with well let me that everyone
needs a house and you should be in a
house and why aren't you in a house and
renting's a sin it I but I don't like
the first sentence I've never heard
somebody say you need a house just to
have one nobody says that that is
twisting an argument to make it sound a
little bit off kilter a little bit dumb
so that then you can pull it apart just
be honest a lot of people particularly
our parents age say if if you rent
something you're just throwing your
money away I've heard that multiple
times from people a generation or two
well-meaning people exactly and in their
world that was accurate in our world
it's not renting is a wise thing I've
I've rented it every stage of my life
whenever time me and my wife move and me
and my kids move we rent until we get
set right so just like you said you're
exactly right it's not logical or
realistic for a lot of people right now
yeah cool make peace with it so that's
okay now should it be a long-term goal I
think it's a great goal to have long
term does it need to happen tomorrow no
there's great flexibility there's great
wisdom you're offloading the risk onto
someone else and you're paying for the
privilege of all of that that's right
that's a good one all right have three
to six months worth of expenses in your
account in case of emergency that's
great but when I can barely make all my
bills each month what money am I
supposed to be saving so they agree with
the advice that you should have a
savings account an emergency fund but
they're angry uh that people are
recommending this as if it's some
something they can just go do and the
conversations I've had around this
around this very this very issue over my
career most of the people in my career
that I've hired
um
were it was their first or second job
they were they were new to the job world
and so there was an expectation that now
that I've got this degree and this
position at this University this this
degree with this this many years of
experience the world's just gonna hand
me this much money
and unfortunately often this is what
this job paid
and so it was less about where's all
this money I'm supposed to be saving and
more about sitting back and going okay I
wanted to do this career and I wanted to
make this much money right now the world
isn't paying this much money for this
career I need to have a hard
conversation with am I going to change
my am I going to reduce how much I spend
am I going to get a new job am I going
to move right all all
incredibly hard conversations but the
idea that I went and did a thing I got
this education I got this training and I
want to live here and I want to work
there and I want to make this much money
those three things are not automatic and
they often don't work together and man
we have a culture that's having a hard
time reconciling those three things well
they were sold a lot of lies and now
they're met with a harsh reality right
and so the gap between those two just
keeps I watched Friends I want to work
in a retail store have a 4 000 square
foot apartment in downtown where it's
just not I've been watching Seinfeld
Kramer is unemployed the entire series
and a guy lives in a New York apartment
across the hall from a comedian right
gosh what a sitcom all right last one
for you John this is a very close to
home someone said the majority of Dave
Ramsey's Financial advice especially if
you're working on paying off debt the
only time you should see the inside of a
restaurant is if you're working there
with the student loan crisis as it is my
20 meal at a restaurant once a month
isn't going to make a difference in
whether I pay off 50 Grand in student
loans I've paid my loans every single
month and right now I owe more than I
originally took out 10 years ago all due
to student loan interest I'm done with
the shaming and being told I don't
deserve a life or the ability to be out
in public
that's right that's that's always been
Dave's advice you're not allowed to be
out in public John yeah Dave's big on
shaming people and telling them they
don't deserve a life I think he's in
Cabo right now if I'm not mistaken I
think so living here last we checked I I
I mean again this is someone who's
struggling and is upset and I'm not I'm
not going to be mad
um well because to them all they have in
life John is this takeout meal that's it
that's all they're left with but it's a
symbol it's saying what are you willing
to sacrifice right now that will add up
to where you have 500 bucks that month
and then 600 bucks the next month to
where you can be debt free one day
twenty dollars against fifty thousand
that's right that's good math
that's not how often people go to
restaurants that's also doesn't take
into account the hours you could be
working instead of sitting in that
restaurant earning more the other way
right so anyway there's a whole
different conversation here this is just
a tough Spirit to work through and if
you have this attitude heading into any
problem in your life yeah you're not
going to get solved this fatalistic
attitude isn't going to get us anywhere
so we've got to change our attitude
change our Behavior change our thoughts
we're rooting for you all out there this
is the Ramsay show